this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer one of the first
things you learn in mechanical
engineering is how to design your
inventions in a way that is possible to
manufacture and assemble this is a skill
that takes time to learn primarily by
working with machinists to look at your
design and laugh at the incompetence of
this young college kid from placing
fastener holes and inaccessible
locations to placing sharp inner corners
that no milling machine can achieve so
much of our engineering capabilities are
dictated by what we can manufacture and
every time a new method of manufacturing
is invented it
oh sure Zin new technologies once deemed
impossible just as the simple cylinder
boring machine facilitated the
Industrial Revolution 3d printing may
now be opening doors to new designs
complicated hollow structures are now
possible allowing designers to integrate
cooling ducts directly into parts an
incredibly useful tool for
high-temperature parrots like turbine
blades and rocket nozzles we can perform
something called topology optimization
where we use finite element analysis a
type of stress simulation to tell us
exactly where material is needed
allowing us to generate the perfect
structure for our application similar to
how hollow bones are formed and thus
allowing us to save on weight helping
lightweight vehicles to gain even more
performance often parts are machined
down from joint blocks of raw material
to their final form in aviation we
measure this waste with the body to fly
ratio which divides the weight of the
final part by the weight of the raw
material it was manufactured from
imagine taking a material like titanium
alloy which can cost upwards of $30 per
kilo and then throwing away 90% of it in
the manufacturing process needless to
say this is a massive source of
increased costs that 3d printing could
help reduce all of these benefits can
come together to unshackle engineers to
form the perfectly shaped objects and
perhaps one of the most interesting
applications of this is this incredible
3d printed aerospike rocket engine that
has the
corporated liquid cooling channels
directly into the rocket nozzles
interior and shaped everything optimally
to provide a highly efficient rocket
nozzle that can operate efficiently at
many different altitudes but even with
all these amazing applications we rarely
see 3d printed parts outside of
prototyping applications like this it's
clear that 3d printing can take human
manufacturing to its next evolution but
what's holding it back as usual the
first problem is cost if we plot the
price of a 3d printed parrot as a
function of the number of parts created
it would look something like this its
price will be dominated by initial
machined costs and that line will only
marginally trend downwards as we print
more parts due to the insane time it
takes to print a single parrot after all
we are essentially welding hundreds of
kilometres of metal powder together to
scale up our manufacturing we need to
buy additional machines which will not
lower our cost this turns our
traditional economies of scale on its
head take an injection molded part early
on the cost will be dominated by the
cost of creating an expensive mold
needed to form the part but once that is
finalized this machine can churn out
piece after piece in rapid succession we
mostly just have to wait for the plastic
to cool down before we can eject it from
the mold and restart the process this
results in a graph that looks something
like this where our cost per pair
rapidly decreases as we build more soon
becoming dominated by the material costs
this means that it only makes economic
sense to use 3d printing for parts that
fall behind this break-even point which
is why it is used so frequently in rapid
prototyping if we can reduce the raw
material cost with better supply and
decrease 3d printer machine costs we can
lower this line and open up more parts
to being replaced by 3d printing that is
gradually happening as the cost of these
machines lower in large part due to
patents expiring in the last 5 years
however it's not just cost preventing 3d
printed parts from entering the market
this month I spoke with Professor Roger
Reed the founder of ox met a company
taking on the challenge of developing
metal alloys and printing techniques to
improve the material properties of these
additive manufactured parts to get a
better idea of the material science that
prevents 3d printed parts from being
approved for even specialized small
batch applications we have thousands of
years of experience mostly through trial
and error of learning how manufacturing
techniques affect the material
properties of the metals we use from
learning how to tailor carbon content
during iron ore smelting to learning how
each hammer blow can affect the
crystalline structure of the metal in
particular we've learned how the exact
way we heat and cool metal affects its
material properties as a result of its
internal crystalline structure but
additive manufacturing throws away much
of the techniques we've developed
forcing us to build much of our
understanding up from scratch and
develop completely novel techniques for
studying and optimizing our material
properties one of the key areas of
research in this regard is improving 3d
printed metal fatigue life the fatigue
life is a measure of how many cycles of
stress a part can sustain before
breaking because materials can fracture
even below their ultimate strength if
you cycle them at a lower stress for
extended periods this affects every
metal and as the reason continual
maintenance is always needed for
machinery we can visualize a materials
fatigue strength by plotting on an SN
curve which places the magnitude of the
alternating stress on the y-axis and the
number of cycles it survived on the
y-axis for traditionally machined
titanium it looks something like this
whereas for 3d printed parts it looks
more like this but simply 3d printed
parts fail much sooner
stopping many of the parts from being
approved for applications they are best
suited for like aviation so why does
this happen first we need to understand
what causes fatigue fractures the
primary cause of these fractures is
crack growth where small voids and
imperfections within the parish can for
stress to divert and pie
in sharp corners and thus exceed the
metals strength locally and cause the
crack to grow the more imperfections
present the more likely your fatigue
life is going to suffer and 3d printed
materials tend to have a lot of
imperfections we got a clearer look at
why this happens when researchers used
high-speed synchrotron x-ray imaging to
get this phenomenal footage of the laser
melting process which revealed many of
the phenomenon resulting in
imperfections here we have a powder bed
of iron nickel alloy called invar 36
which has been turned into a powder by
blasting a stream of molten metal with a
high-pressure gas this process is called
atomization as the laser moves across
the powder bed it melts it essentially
forming a weld line you can see that
this layer tended to dig into the powder
bed creating a track that varies in
height these sort of imperfections means
the final product needs a surface
machining to create a quality part
although it's important to note that
this study was specifically studying
something called an overhang condition
where the parent has no structure below
it and has to build on the loose bed of
powder instead as the laser matches on
the powder in front of it gets blown
away meaning the laser no longer has
metal powder to melt in that region and
instead forms new beads of molten metal
ahead of the original track which
eventually coalesce with the original
finally we see some worrisome behavior
as the laser reaches the end of this
track as the molten metal begins to cool
we see pores begin to form in the upper
surface of the track the exact kind of
imperfections that could allow crack
growth to occur in the future this study
also varied several factories like laser
speed and laser power to study their
effects on the melt tracks properties
here they increase the speed of the
laser to a point where the metal
particles did not have enough time to
heat up and coalesce in another
experiment they investigated the
interaction of two melt rocks here you
can see more pores forming as a result
of overhangs trapping gas and yet more
porous form in the same manner as before
as we reach the end of the track
clearly this process is much more
complicated than just melting some metal
powder together and in the end the final
products that come directly out of a 3d
printer are far from finished and need a
significant amount of post-processing
for example we can help close these
pores by using a method called hot
isostatic pressing where we apply heat
and very high ISO static pressure which
just means the pressure is the same in
all directions this maintains the
overall part shape but compresses and
heats the part up enough to close those
pores to improve our fatigue strength
but not enough to compete with
traditionally machined parts this of
course pushes the cost bar higher making
3d printing again
less attractive for applications outside
of rapid prototyping and we have yet
more material property issues to address
we explored the science of forging with
my friend Alec Steele in a previous
video we learned how the internal
crystal grain structure is one of the
most influential factors in determining
and materials final material properties
we can control the materials hardness
and ductility by simply heating and
cooling it in a particular way typically
when a piece of molten metal is cooled
crystals grow at random from individual
nucleation sites and form crystal grains
the size and structure of these grains
dictates so many of the metals final
material properties and we've learned
over thousands of years of metal forging
how to get the best out of our materials
once again additive manufacturing throws
much of this knowledge out the window
leaving us to start from scratch we have
learned that 3d printed materials tend
to have these columnar grains that rise
up in the direction of the print and the
grains tend to follow the direction of
the laser forming directional grain
structures that can almost be thought of
like the grains in a piece of wood this
means that how the laser mousse has a
massive effect on the material
properties of the material and thus we
can use this to our advantage by
tailoring our laser scan strategy one of
the most common laser scan strategies is
the island scan strategy where a pattern
like this is formed creating 5
millimeter
of laser trackpads oriented
perpendicularly to each other these
islands are formed in a random sequence
this scan strategy developed by concept
laser was created to alleviate residual
stresses that form as a result of uneven
heating and cooling within the metal
which can decrease the part's overall
strength just another factor designers
have to consider and often requires the
part to be placed in an oven after
printing to help alleviate residual
stresses however one study found that
this scan strategy has some unique
effects on the grain structure creating
those aforementioned vertical grain
structures with fine grain boundaries
between each island and these fine grain
boundaries had a high density of cracks
which again can grow and cause fatigue
failure there are of course alternative
laser scan strategies like this helical
one other researchers are attempting to
use thermal and other specialized
cameras inside the building to observe
the phenomenon like pore formation and
informed the laser exactly how to
operate with machine learning to
maximize material properties well I
don't see this manufacturing technique
ever being used for low-cost high-volume
parts where other manufacturing
techniques are much better suited if we
can improve the fatigue life of these
metals we could start seeing them appear
in more applications like that
incredible 3d printed aerospike engine
we saw earlier this is a very new area
of research that could use more ice just
as I learned how to design to get the
best out of carbon fiber composites and
molded plastics over the course of my
university life and industry experience
we are now seeing young engineers
beginning their education with this form
of design in mind allowing them to
create designs that were once deemed
impossible I believe there is going to
be a fascinating meeting of material
science and machine learning in the
space to customize laser scanning
patterns for particular parts and allow
the machine to spot and fix defects as
they happen and I would imagine the
overlap of material scientists and
machine learning coders is a small pool
of people at the moment so perhaps this
could be a career path for you
and he could start working towards it
right now by taking this course on
machine learning on brilliant this
course will help you develop the
mathematical skills needed to deeply
understand how problems of
classification and estimation work and
by the end of it you will develop the
techniques needed to take complex
multivariable data sets and create
machine learning algorithms to analyze
them or you could complete one of
brilliants daily challenges each day
brilliant presents you with interesting
scientific and mathematical problems to
test your brain each daily challenge
provides you with the context and
framework that you need to tackle is
allowing you to learn the concepts by
applying them if you like the problem
and want to learn more there's a course
quiz that explores the same concept in
greater detail if you are confused and
need more guidance there's a community
of thousands of learners discussing the
problems and writing solutions daily
challenges are thought-provoking
challenges that will lead you from
curiosity to mastery one day at a time
if I've inspired you and you want to
educate yourself then go to brilliant
org ford slash real engineering and sign
up for free and the first 500 people
that go to that link will get 20% off
the annual premium subscription so you
can get full access to all their courses
as well as the entire daily challenges
archive as always thanks for watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below